Hey youtubers it's Charlie hopefully by now
you've had a chance to watch the Season 4
finale.
Now it's time to talk about the possibilities
of season 5.
I think the most interesting conversation
isn't so much about what they're going to
do from the books, but about what they're
going to change.
Dan and Dave did say there would be even more
changes next season.
So what I'm going to do in this video is just
go down the cast list and talk a little about
what I would like to see from each character
next season, I'll make sure to say if someone
had a bunch of changes this season.
Because that will affect what happens to them
in the future.
I'm going to do all the character from the
finale first just because we just got done
watching them, then I'll circle back around
and do the other big characters.
In case I feel like this video gets too long
just because there are so many characters,
I'll just break it up and do smaller characters
in another video.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I try to keep all my videos under 12 or 13
minutes.
But there's so many characters, we could just
keep going all day.
If you didn't see it, there's still time to
enter the giveaway.
Just make sure you watch my finale video after
you get done watching this video for details.
I'll add a link for that in the description.
Careful for spoilers from the finale if you
haven't seen it yet.
And quick heads up on future spoilers.
I don't consider any of the stuff I'm going
to talk about to be major spoilers for the
books or anything.
Most of all my conclusions are based on contextual
clues from season 4 episodes.
Especially the big changes Dan and Dave made.
So here we go, starting with Tyrion and Varys
who are basically travel companions now.
There were a few callbacks to season 2 and
3 scenes in their final moments.
First was the Box.
All I could think about was Varys Sorcerer
that he captured.
That was the exact same type of box.
Then there was the bells.
Back during Blackwater, Varys said he always
hated the bells because they always ring for
horror.
Like a dead king or a city under seige.
Tyrion joked that they also ring for weddings,
which I guess you could consider a moment
of foreshadowing for the red wedding, which
hadn't happened at that point.
Weddings on Game of Thrones are pretty horrific.
The boat they're on is headed east, because
there's not really anywhere in Westeros they'd
be safe after what happened.
Varys probably would have been fine, but remember
how hard he's been working to strengthen the
realm.
Cersei is in charge again now that Tywin is
gone.
She won't have to marry Loras and Twyin won't
be there to stop her from indulging every
whim.
She's not a monster like Joffrey, but she
is a really selfish person.
And now she has free reign.
Number 2 - Cersei and Jaime
Cersei as discussed will figure out that she's
in charge again and put the brakes on anything
she doesn't like.
On the bonus side, she'll be able to spend
all her time watching over Tommen and Ser
Pounce.
I'll say Ser Pounce is someone I hope the
include at least once next year.
The director of that episode said to not expect
him back, but I think it would be a lot of
fun.
Jaime looks like he's still stuck between
wanting to do great deeds worthy of the White
Book and his love for Cersei.
It's a pretty toxic love so I fully expect
him to continue flip flop back
and forth.
Number 3 - Up at the Wall, Stannis, Melisandre
and Jon Snow
Stannis has a massive army there now, paid
for with the Iron Bank's money.
A lot of their money.
His army is big enough to man some of the
other castles along the wall.
So I really hope they build sets for those
locations, like the Night Fort.
It's possible that they could just spend the
entire season just at Castle Black too.
Melisandre gave Jon that long stare through
the flames.
Anytime she stares at someone it either means
she's going to have sex with them at some
point or use them in some horrific plot.
Or in the case of Gendry, both.
For now it just seems like she's going to
shift her focus to him.
We don't really know what she's planning with
Shireen.
Even though we didn't see her in the episode
remember how she insisted that Stannis bring
her to The Wall with them.
Melisandre has always said that Stannis was
Azor Ahai but I'd love to see her put that
on Jon Snow.
He and Stannis shared that long look of understanding
about burning the bodies so he understands
the threat of the white walkers.
But I don't expect Jon to completely buy into
anything Melisandre might see in the flames
as regards him.
Remember, Jojen said that only the green dreams
always come true.
Visions in the flames can be things that might
have happened, they're not always things that
will happen.
Number 4 - On to Bran's Group
It seemed like a lot of you guys were more
interested in talking about Jojen's death
as it affects the story more than what was
going on with Bran so I'll start with that.
All of the Jojen stuff that happens in the
books after they arrive at the tree is in
Dance with Dragons so Bran's story on the
show was taken a lot from that book.
He doesn't really appear in book 4.
Books 4 and 5 occur during the same time period
though.
So think of it as one giant book split in
half.
In the book Jojen still has visions of his
death, it just happens in a different way,
so on the show when the Three Eye Raven said
that Jojen always knew he was going to die,
he was acknowledging that fate.
I think the show changed his death just because
it was more efficient and they didn't want
to include his character next season.
But from a story standpoint, he'd served his
purpose, he was only there to help Bran reach
the Three Eye Raven, which he did.
As for Meera, she's basically done too.
She was mostly Jojen's caregiver, since she's
still alive I think she'll stay and help Bran
with Hodor, although Bran won't really need
Hodor as much since they're in that cave now.
The Child of the Forest is kind of like the
Hodor for the Three Eyed Raven, just serving
support functions.
Number 5 - Arya Stark
She's one of the few characters that's on
her own.
Gendry is the other big one that comes to
mind.
Just someone who isn't traveling with another
main character.
Her ship is headed to Braavos, so she's probably
going to pick up where she left off with Jaquen
H'gar.
Because Arya's story is a huge part of the
books that the show hasn't done yet please
be careful if you want to comment about book
spoilers.
I won't say what happens to her character,
but I predict that the show will follow her
story in the book pretty closely.
If you haven't read the books and want to
read that part.
Arya's story picks up in Book 4 Arya Chapter
1.
She's a POV character in book 4.
That first chapter of her's takes place immediately
after that last scene with her on the boat
in the finale.
So anyone who wants to read the books during
the hiatus, Book 4 would be a good place to
start if you don't want to read the first
3 books.
I understand a lot of you totally don't care
about that and just want to watch the show.
Number 6 - Brienne and Podrick
Brienne is alive and mostly well after her
fight with the hound.
They changed her plot in the books significantly,
but I think she'll just resume her search
for Sansa and head toward the Bloody Gate.
If they make it there I don't expect Sansa
and Littlefinger to still be there.
Number 7 - Sansa and Littlefinger
Back when Black Hair Sansa was saying 'shall
we go' she was referring the Littlefinger's
plan to take Robyn Arryn on a tour of his
holdings.
So they'll just head out and start traveling
all around the Vale.
If you look at the map here it's actually
pretty big, so there are a number of places
they can visit.
Number 8 - Reek and Ramsay Bolton
A lot of Theon's story this year like the
Moat Cailin bits are from Dance with Dragons,
but there's a lot of stuff they haven't done
from the books yet.
So I'll say the same as for Arya's book story.
Please be careful if you want to comment about
spoilers.
But I expect them to follow Theon's books
story pretty closely.
If you want to read those parts but you haven't
read book 4 you won't really be spoiling yourself.
Because it's all happening at the same time.
But if you want to read ahead you should start
at Reek Chapter 2 in Dance with Dragons.
That's pretty much it for the biggest characters.
I know we haven't seen Bronn in a long time
but he's mostly porking his new wife.
He's still a main cast member who has not
died yet.
So he'll definitely be part of the story in
King's Landing next season.
Since there are a billion secondary characters
we can just discuss them in the comments.
So if there's someone I didn't include in
the video just write them in the comments.
I know a lot of you are asking about 2 big
characters the show didn't use and if you
know who I'm talking about then all I'll say
is I don't think we'll see them next season
either.
Apparently they were never on the table during
story planning.
So it's not like they cut them out at the
last minute.
On the topic of book changes, Dan and Dave
said even more things would be changing.
But mostly what I think will change is which
characters run into each other.
I think we'll see a few unexpected run-ins
with people in Braavos and eventually Meereen.
Braavos is a lot closer to Westeros so I'm
hoping we see Gendry there but his character
has changed so much from the books it's hard
to tell where we'll see him next.
Also I've already talked a lot about the new
Dorne Martell characters, so I'll add a link
in the description for that.
But they are filming in Spain, so I'm really
excited to see those locations.
In related news, my next video will be the
Q&A.
I'll try to post that by tonight.
You can follow me on social for video updates
if you aren't already.
If I'm running behind I usually try to tell
people.
I'm also going to be going to VidCon in two
weeks.
If any of you guys are going and want to do
a meet up just let me know and I'll arrange
something.
I'll be posting a special VidCon video explaining
what I'm doing though.
Right now click here for the Q&A, I'll add
the annotation as soon as I post it and click
here for my Finale video.
Thanks for watching everyone, see you guys
tonight.
High Fives!